también la luz alcalde francés está
frustrado de la lentitud de la
vacunación en francia junto a 100 ediles
de la región del exxon al suroeste de
parís dirigieron una carta abierta al
presidente macrón un 9 no nos
consultaron para nada sobre la
estrategia de la inoculación con la
carta queríamos decir estamos aquí
cuenten con nosotros para montar la
estrategia de vacunación tenemos nuestra
visión experiencia expertise según el
alcalde él es capaz de abrir un centro
de vacunación en 72 horas de hecho cree
que los espacios levantados para hacer
los test anti covite en su comuna como
este consultorio pueden ser usados
también para vacunar en cadena pero está
médico que trabaja allí está preocupada
por la logística necesaria a la hora de
vacunar en masa
y conocemos los efectos secundarios dos
gestos para poner la vacuna el
seguimiento es bastante simple pero para
mí el mayor problema es la organización
no estoy segura de que tengamos médicos
y enfermeras todo el tiempo y cada día
junto al noreste de parís se ubica el
leonés y una comuna acomodada su alcalde
y ramis el yen este se cansó de esperar
la luz verde del gobierno para vacunar a
los habitantes cuando uno es alcalde y
siente que puede poner en riesgo a su
población uno hace todo lo que pueda
para protegerles tome el teléfono y
llamé a los laboratorios quería saber si
podían venderme vacunas pero me
respondieron que la prioridad es para
los estados
si hay 15.000 habitantes y en este
gimnasio esperan instalar el primer
centro de vacunación para inocular de
200 a 300 personas por día las primeras
inyecciones deben empezar el primero de
febrero con cita previa pero al día de
hoy el estado solo es capaz de entregar
420 dosis por semana